gay marriage it hasn't been on such a
roll since Bert and Ernie first
co-signed their lease on Sesame Street
Washington State has followed
Massachusetts New York's netiquette New
Hampshire Vermont Iowa and the District
of Columbia to become the latest
jurisdiction in the u.s. to legally
recognize domestic bliss between men and
men and women and women New Jersey is
poised to jump on the big gay bandwagon
and a recent Court decision in
California has invalidated that face
proposition 8 which bans same-sex
marriage last year for the first time
four national polls found a majority of
Americans favor gay marriage and there's
an ever-shrinking minority of objectors
but don't bust out the opportunities and
Indigo Girls cities just yet
last year when the deep blue state of
Maryland voted on gay marriage everyone
expected the birth date of John Waters
to go all in on my big fat gay wedding
after weeks of intense lobbying and
debate the votes for passage simply
weren't there
understanding what happened is essential
to the future success of same-sex
marriage and it's worth understanding
what's fake too
here's Justin and Phillip Terry Smith
two residents of Maryland who were
especially disappointed by last year's
failure to launch you know we love each
other so why on earth would we not go
for marriage for these guys to be more
than just roommates in the Terrapins
state they'll have to overcome
opposition from social conservatives on
both sides of the aisle I mean if we're
gonna protect something it ought to be
protecting marriage between one man and
one woman
gays the lesbians have never been
discriminated like I've been this indeed
recent Washington Post polls of Maryland
voters show that while 71% of white
Democrats support gay marriage only 41%
of blacks do because of that intra-party
split successful gay marriage campaign
tactic cross party lines to grip spit
and get her done
that's how New York succeeded is 33 nays
29 Democratic reached around to
libertarian Republicans to create a
bulletproof majority and that's what
Maryland Governor Martin O'Malley a
Democrat is doing this time there is
little doubt gay marriage will
ultimately prevail it is on an express
train to Universal passage the
only remaining question is how long will
opponent's marriage is the union between
a man and a woman make gay and lesbian
couples wait to join long suffering
heterosexuals in getting married and
divorced happily ever after for recent
TV I'm Kennedy